[MUSIC PLAYING]
WESLEY: Hi, and welcome to
"Serverless Migration Station."
I'm Wesley from Google,
joined by Martin,
to help you modernize
your apps running
on one of our serverless
compute platforms.
In this and the next
migration module,
our little friend
Porter will take you
on a journey to
migrate from App Engine
Memcache to Cloud Memorystore.
But we need to start
using Memcache first
before we can migrate
to Memorystore,
so this video won't feature
any migrating at all.
MARTIN: Really?
More nonmigration content
in a migration video series?
WESLEY: You caught me again.
Yes, Porter does take users
from point A to point B,
but we need to first take a
detour to reacquaint folks
with App Engine Memcache.
We'll add Memcache usage to the
module 1 Flask App Engine NDB
app.
Then we can migrate it to
Cloud Memorystore next time,
in module 13.
MARTIN: Sounds good.
Where do we start?
WESLEY: We're going to
begin with the module 1 app,
the one we just migrated
from webapp 2 to Flask,
and add use of App
Engine Memcache to it.
Here's a link to that
module 1 codelab and video
so you can review
it, if necessary.
MARTIN: That sounds good, Wes.
Now both of those
are in Python 2.
What about Python 3 developers?
WESLEY: Yeah.
Until fall 2021, you couldn't
port the module 1 Flask app
to Python 3 because it uses
App Engine bundled services--
in this case, NDB.
Once this feature
launched, Python 3 users
are now able to access many
of those services which
brought users to App Engine.
We'll cover this new feature
in another video soon.
But suffice it to say that
users can port the module 1
app to Python 3 first
or add Memcache,
like we're going to do today,
and then upgrade to Python 3.
Either way works.
MARTIN: Sounds good, Wes.
What are we going to use
Memcache for in our sample app?
WESLEY: I'm glad you
asked because I was just
about to get into that.
As you know, our app creates a
new entity for each page visit.
Because it only shows the
10 most recent visitors,
there's no need to create new
visits if the same user keeps
hitting our website, right?
So we'll just cache
the most recent visits
for an hour for the same user.
If a new user comes along,
that will reset the cache.
Also, the cache will
expire after an hour.
Sound good?
MARTIN: OK.
But I have to be honest.
I haven't used App Engine
Memcache in quite a while.
Can I get my hands
dirty and do it myself,
while you are
showing us onscreen?
WESLEY: Absolutely.
Go grab the module 1 code,
if you did the codelab,
or clone the repo or download
the ZIP file if you didn't.
Pause here if you
need to do that.
Module 1 is where we'll start.
If you want to do
this by hand with me
now or on your own time,
follow the module 12 codelab.
Ready?
Let's go to the computer
now and do this.
Because it's always good to
start from a working app,
use gcloud app deploy to
redeploy your module 1 app
and ensure it works
before we update it.
Python 3 users can delete
the appengine_config.py file
and relax for a bit, while
Python 2 developers install
the third-party libraries into
the lib folder with the pip
install command
you see onscreen.
Then everyone can
use gcloud app deploy
to upload the app
to the cloud, then
confirm that that module
1 app still works.
Now we can add
some caching to it.
Before we make
changes, be aware you
won't see a difference
in output afterwards.
Instead, we're just going to
avoid the extra Datastore calls
and see lower latency.
With that out of
the way, let's start
with the imports at the top.
All that's needed is to bring
in the App Engine Memcache
library.
Since we're going to
cache for an hour,
add a constant for that.
Register visits, querying for
the latest visits to display,
and other Datastore
calls stay the same.
The biggest updates to the code
are in the main application.
So visits are determined
by a visitor's IP address,
along with a user agent.
In the original app, we create
the visit entity immediately.
In the update, we save
the visitor info first,
then try to get the latest
visits from the cache.
If the cache is empty
or it's a new visitor,
save this as the newest visit.
Fetch all the latest
visits from Datastore
and cache them for an hour,
in case the same visitor
comes back sooner.
And that's all that's necessary
to change this app to add
caching to the module 1 app.
So now just save and
gcloud app deploy
to see our updated
app in action.
Again, the output
doesn't change,
but what you should notice
is that page refreshes
will be much quicker.
Hit your app from
another computer
or wait for more
than an hour to see
that the app goes back
to its original latency
in fetching of the initial data.
Now, before we get back to
the main part of the show,
we want to acknowledge that
most of the migration effort
is directed to Python 2 users
to get them to the latest App
Engine runtimes.
Onscreen now are the Python
2 and 3 versions of the app.
The differences you see are
what Python 2 developers
have to do to port
their apps to Python 3.
This is an addition to any
other Python 2-to-3 migration
steps you need to implement.
Our sample app is simple enough
that it runs on Python 2 and 3
without modification.
So what you see is how to
access App Engine bundled
services in Python 3.
More details can be found
in the Docs link below,
as well as how to access
these services from Java 11,
Go 1.12 and newer, and PHP 7.
OK, now let's go back to
the main presentation.
MARTIN: Thanks for
the tutorial, Wes.
Now where should I go if I
want to reacquaint myself
with App Engine Memcache?
WESLEY: Yes, I'd say start
with the Memcache overview
page in the docs.
For specific details, also check
out the Memcache reference docs
in Python 2 or in Python 3.
MARTIN: Cool.
I'll take a look.
But can you give me a heads
up on what we're doing next?
WESLEY: Sure, Martin.
Now that we have App
Engine Memcache in our app,
we'll migrate to Cloud
Memorystore in module 13.
If you want to read
ahead, check out the links
to the migration page, as well
as the Cloud Memorystore docs.
You can also take a look
at the module 13 codelab
to see what we'll
discuss in that video.
Of course, there are plenty of
other migrations to consider.
But, at the end
of this module 12,
you can get off at this station,
staying on App Engine Memcache,
or consider that upgrade
to Cloud Memorystore.
And we look forward
to having you join us
for that discussion
in module 13.
This is Wesley, on behalf
of Martin and Porter,
and we hope to see you at
that next Migration Station
or on another Serverless
Expedition soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]